you make me laugh step brothers drake
parker and josh nichols may have been
polar opposites but there's one thing
they both struggled with
girls we're not talking about their
devious younger sister megan either
while drake spent the series trying to
hold a steady relationship
josh struggled with building up the
courage to complement his crushes
all in all it led to some petty hillary
scenarios and unforgettable moments for
viewers
from jake's one episode of flings to
josh's adorable but angsty relationship
with mindy
we're taking you on a trip down memory
lane here's everything you need to know
about all of drake and josh's very
unique relationships
josh nichols and mindy crenshaw two
names that no drake and josh fans could
ever forget
for a lot of viewers this on and off
couple was probably their first
ever ship although it wasn't always
smooth sailing
this is the only romantic relationship
in the series that lasted until the very
end
starting off as rivals at school no one
could ever guess what the future held
for these two
josh and mindy were constantly competing
for the top spot in the class
face it josh you can't beat me at
anything oh yeah
and faced each other year after year at
the school science fair
but the angst built up into something
more during one of their many fights the
two
ended up angrily admitting to liking
each other and when mindy suggests they
date
all josh had to say was one condition
what i get to be
the boyfriend but their competitiveness
with one another soon turned into some
major relationship drama
breaking the news to drake took a major
toll on their relationship
especially because creature was a
nickname of choice for mindy
hello creature but when drake tells his
stepbrother
she makes you happy then i'm happy they
form a plan to help josh get mindy back
the two end up having their first kiss
at her bedroom window with josh standing
on drake's shoulders
it wasn't a happy ending for the pair
just yet when the science fair rolls
around once again they get right back
into their rivalry and when josh thinks
mindy professes her love to distract him
from making his proton laser
things get messy they break up once
again and the episodes leading up to the
series finale are full of fights
angsty makeout sessions and more
competition however fans got their end
game when the two sit next to each other
at helen's wedding when josh
asks if they should get back together
mindy replies okay
but i get to be the girlfriend and the
rest is history
well ha
unlike his brother josh who preferred
long-term relationships drake parker had
many many many girlfriends
right from the very first episode the
first one viewers got to know was
tiffany
although she was dating the school's
football player buck she agreed to go
out with drake however buck crashes
their date and ends up mistaking
josh for drake josh is challenged to a
fight
and to prepare the brothers hilarious
sign up for karate lessons
in hopes they'll learn how to defend
themselves josh ends up getting punched
in the face
making him really angry at drake for
getting him into the situation
in the end the viewers learn that no
girlfriend is worth ruining their
brotherly bond over
tiffany wasn't the only relationship
drake had that josh got in hot water
susan who was also introduced early on
in the season was dating drake
but has some major ulterior motives
susan was actually super obsessed with
josh and was his first ever kiss when
she confronts
josh about her feelings and kisses him
drake catches them and throws a wedge
between the brothers
although josh tries to prove his
innocence drake sides with his
girlfriend suen
it is until jake remembers that he
actually has the entire encounter
recorded
that's that's not what it looks like
yeah neither are you
and josh's name is cleared the
stepbrothers stayed in good standing and
susan was sent packing
there was even an episode in season two
where drake had not one but two suitors
usually megan is the one terrorizing her
brothers but in this episode it honestly
wasn't her doing
while dating larissa megan brings home a
friend named wendy who ends up having
the biggest crush
on drake uh he's only the cutest boy
ever when drake takes larissa on a date
to the premier theater
megan and wendy's girl scout group just
happens to be on a field trip at the
premiere as well
wendy crashes the day to making fun of
larissa and complaining that drake
didn't get her a present while dealing
with wendy
larissa leaves and we never hear or see
from her again
although megan had nothing to do with it
we can bet that she was pretty content
with her meddling friend wendy
next up is kelly you guessed it she was
also one of drake's girlfriends in the
episode
mean teacher although drake likes to
spend time with kelly he just can't get
over her annoying laugh
basically she was the janus of drake and
josh but when drake contemplated
breaking up with her he finds out that
she's actually the daughter of his most
despised teacher
mrs hafer when she finds out about the
two of them she threatens drake by
saying
you break her heart you're going to
summer school
drake spends the entire episode trying
to come up with a way
to not only get out of the relationship
but the dreaded upcoming
summer school with mrs hafer luckily for
him kelly ends things before he has to
it doesn't make his relationship with
mrs hayfer any better
but at least he doesn't have to trade
the beach for the classroom
wedding bells even ring for drake in the
season 3 episode we're married when
josh's online pen pal yuka comes to
visit from eudonia
things take a turn real quick right off
the bat viewers know there's chemistry
between
yuka and drake especially when she
mistakes him for josh
during their first meeting in an attempt
to spend as much time as possible with
yooka
josh arranges a friendship ceremony for
the three of them that accidentally ties
the knot between drake and yuka
while drake is definitely into her he
just wasn't ready for marriage
the two brothers come up with a plan
that had her father tearing up the
marriage certificate before you could
even say
pen pal they fed her family goat an
animal that's absolutely sacred in their
culture
that's right drake is technically
divorced moral of the episode don't
arrange a friendship ceremony for your
internet pen pals
season three of drake and josh included
an episode called playing the field and
that's exactly what drake did
not wanting to label his relationship
with tori he gets pushed into a corner
when she refers to him as her boyfriend
boyfriend the cutest in return he breaks
up with her
when tory visits the premier theater
with a guy that next day
drake tries to push aside his jealousy
but josh helps him realize he made a
huge mistake
in order to get her back he uses liza to
make her jealous
tori sees right through him but in a
turn of events his skewed plan of using
liza is actually successful
although it all works out in drake's
favor and the two start dating we never
see tori in future episodes
the relationship in the episode girl
power was a tough break for drake
he's completely smitten with his new
girlfriend lucy until she defends him
after he gets beat up by a football
player before drake can even react to
getting pushed down
she gets involved and literally manages
to throw drake's bully across the room
although he pretends to be grateful for
her stepping in he just can't get past
the fact that he could be dating someone
who is tougher than he is
when josh confronts him about it he
denies that he's uncomfortable but
eventually brings it up to lucy
the couple arrange a fight to settle
their dispute once and for all
but while doing so he ends up crashing
josh's second chance at impressing
mindy's parents
the fight ends in a draw but drake and
lucy decide that it's probably still
best they go their separate ways
as for josh and mindy her parents
approve of josh after he stands up for
her and shows the crenshaw's that he
actually really values their
relationship
that wasn't the end of lucy though we'll
take a look later on in the video at
lucy's cameo
in drake and josh's later seasons and
how she poses a huge threat to one of
drake's future relationships
although drake's relationship with
rebecca in season 3 episode little
sibling
never escalated she's definitely an
honorable mention considering she was
played by the iconic vanessa hudgins
rebecca helps drake sneak into class
lace by telling mrs hafer
mrs haye for the lunch ladies are
fighting again when she runs out to
resolve the fight
drake successfully gets to class and
repays her with a kiss in front of
everyone
we can't forget about how he also
embarrassed josh by tossing him his
ointment he forgot at home
is nothing personal we never see rebecca
again
but we can only imagine it had something
to do with her hanging with zac efron on
another sound stage
tabitha got to share the episode little
sibling as a guest star alongside the
one and only oprah winfrey
in this episode drake is unsurprisingly
so infatuated with his girlfriend
and throws her the biggest surprise
party when josh arrives he thinks the
party is for his birthday
but soon finds out that drake actually
forgot his birthday entirely
his priorities changed real quick when
he realized how much he hurt his brother
completely forgetting about tabitha
drake sets out on a mission to score
josh tickets to a live taping of his
idol oprah's show
in the episode who's got game we were
introduced to drake's girlfriend
carly who is actually the only girl who
returns for another episode
while still in a relationship with him
in good old drake fashion their
relationship didn't start out
conventionally
after another breakup with mindy drake
tries to cheer joshua by holding a
competition
whoever can get a date with the most
girls wins
when drake asks carly as part of the
challenge he doesn't expect to actually
like her
the two start dating until she finds out
she was part of a bat
drake likes her so much that he does
everything he can to prove that he's
trustworthy
but it isn't until he tells all the
girls that we're a part of the bet the
truth that she forgives him and they
begin dating
carly returns as drake's girlfriend in
the episode the storm for a party at
drake and josh's home
little does drake know that lucy his
tough ex-girlfriend
will also be at the party when carly and
lucy hit it off drake worries that lucy
will manage to beat him down again
and embarrass him in front of carly
instead drake actually gets
what to him is the best compliment ever
the girls discuss how amazing of a
kisser he is
although carly appears toward the end of
the series viewers never get any insight
on what happened to their relationship
in the end
drake's excessive dating and josh's
awkwardness may have been a tad dramatic
but it led to some epic comedic moments
not to mention their love life turmoils
really showed how strong drake and
josh's bond was in the end
what was your favorite ship on drake and
josh who do you think drake should have
ended up with in the end
let us know what you think about the
romantic endeavors in the comment
section below
don't forget to hit that subscribe
button and ring that notification bell
for more videos just like this one
until next time